I don't have children but I know that
there must be guilt that probably sets
in you know and that you're away from
them and how you balance that because in
some sense your project is also another
child I know for phone courage this is
like our kid pretty much I mean it needs
constant attention and you feel guilty
when you're away from it I should be
doing so how do you balance that or is
it grounding to come back to knowing
that okay I can turn off the filmmaker
hat now and I can be the moment I could
be grounded and doing things down I
think there's guilt for every mom in all
sorts of situations if you like gave
your kid lots of cookies you feel good
you know like it that's unfortunately
something that runs through Parenthood
and I you know I I really fought against
feeling guilty because mostly you know
it's speaking for myself I feel very
much you know that I'm present in my
home and you know yes we go and shoot
over two years maybe 45 weeks you know
split up into five day increments but
mostly being present in like Sarah said
that I do think it's really important
for them to see you doing what you love
to do and that that is invaluable for
them and also for yourself and it and it
makes your parenting better in a way to
be happy doing what you like to do be
like a little bit obsessed with it I
struggle I i think that there's a
struggle that happens when you're
working super super intensely and then
being sort of required to drop it or
leave it at the door when you walk in is
very challenging and I just I long for
the days before we had email on our
phones and text messages and all of that
like added stuff because I think if I
like one of the biggest stress factors
for me in I'm going here with you guys
because your film courage so I'm talking
about like the the reality of what you
know I felt like but but the you know to
be like hanging trying to come home
trying to be normal and then get like an
email message that something was wrong
or that there was some drama that needed
to be dealt with right away it was so
stressful and I think and I think
there's probably a neurologist would
tell us that there's reasons why that
like being called upon to engage with
kids requires a certain kind of focus
and then being called upon by your
device to put out some other kind of
fire requires a certain kind of focus
and that like the the part of us that
needs flow you know in an inner
experience is so radically disrupted and
then you're probably getting some kind
of like hormonal hit every time you get
an email in your box and you have an
interaction you know and so I think
there's some some place of that's very
interesting to sort of look at like what
are the physical effects because I feel
like my nervous system sort of suffered
a lot from that and I I'm trying now to
like for example not look at my phone or
not look at my email until you know this
kind of cops and so yeah I like but
that's I mean because otherwise it's
just it's madness it's brutal yeah and
there's so many details obviously you
know it's just never ends there's a lot
of people involved in this film like who
are a part of it and there's a lot of
just stuff you know it's constant and
the way that we've approached sort of
the distribution and keeping our hands
on it you know it's not like we just
passed the film off there's a lot of
details and yeah i guess i'm also not to
as filmmakers now that are who are all
all of us are being required to you know
we have the great gift of the social
media and you know kickstarter and
crowdfunding and all of that stuff but
what that means is
that you're interacting directly with
individuals all over the world
electronically all day long and that has
its own kind of like it can be so
sustaining and their kin alt there's
like some like there's like a sliver of
it that can be draining and like God
forbid you got like a hostile email and
it just like you know there's that
contact how comes it like a little bit
of a price i think but mostly people
it's I mean yes especially with like I
didn't receive my Kickstarter Stevie I'm
just like oh my god I'm at the park with
my child how am I gonna deal with this
but like most of the people who have
reached out to us have been sort of full
of gratitude yeah and that is so
sustaining I mean it really you know it
makes us feel better and for all the
hard work that we've done and it's a
labor of love you know for people to say
thank you it ends up being like we tried
a cert said once we need to figure out
how to monetize we have like an
imaginary account we're like thank yous
are worth like you know hundred dollars
until you just like put your imaginary
hundred-dollar thank you thin this
account anyway yeah that's yeah we
probably shouldn't bear that that sounds
crazy
you